there are some questions though now look
I don't want to take away from the
statement the statement was powerful it
was what the players wanted when you
look at the actual language that was
employed
it wasn't a 100 percent capitulation it
was closer to 97 percent because on the
question of whether or not the league
was going to say we should not have
silenced our players that wasn't the
response the response was we apologize
for not listening I don't think they
wanted to cross that bridge into
admitting that they silenced players
whether it's they don't write to they
don't want to deal with the Colin
Kaepernick potential backlash and there
already is some backlash hey what are
you gonna do about Colin Kaepernick now
that you've supposedly had an awakening
but look just because the lawsuit the
Colin Kaepernick brought was settled it
did not completely extinguish all rights
he would have going forward there's a
chance that if they would admit that
they silenced players it would invite
some sort of a second action by
Kaepernick because there was a belief by
Kaepernick's people that once they
settled the case somebody was going to
give him a job and it still hasn't
happened over a year later and you know
my takeaway though is I feel like the
stage is set for maybe a falling of the
ice between Kaepernick and the NFL that
maybe as we continue to put words into
action and time passes
maybe the teams out there that have felt
like we can't do this we shouldn't do
this we mustn't do this for business
reasons or somebody's gonna be matters
with another team or the league or
whatever I feel like that could melt
away Chris and I feel like somebody may
actually put his name back in the pool
of available quarterbacks now look it's
gonna be a minimum salary type thing if
it happens the fact that he's been out
for three years you don't just show up
and get fifteen million dollars a season
but I feel like an opportunity a real
opportunity by the time we get into
August in September and maybe a
quarterback gets injured or test
positive for covert 19 maybe maybe Colin
Kaepernick is on that same list that so
many other quarterbacks are on that
we've seen those names fly off the list
on two teams over the last three years
and we said how the hell does this guy
have a job and not Colin Kaepernick yeah
well I mean we all know that that was a
bunch of crap
there's no other way to say that colin
kaepernick should have been in the NFL
should be in the NFL now there shouldn't
be a question about that I'm with you in
the fact that it feels like the tide has
turned that the NFL might you know
actually really want a Colin Kaepernick
return this type I mean this time around
as far as hey you know the NFL's never
got got in this deep and this type of
fight and I'm it would certainly be you
know good good good attention and you
know good good whatever I'm trying to
say there you know what I mean people
paying attention good good media focus
I'm blanking on the word I want to say
but regardless okay to me the biggest
thing still is going to come down to the
individual team and as much as maybe
they think who this guy was really good
a few years ago and you know he should
have been a starting NFL quarterback and
all that is the individual team itself
still gonna want to deal with the
distraction of Colin Kaepernick and also
trust a guy maybe to be a backup
quarterback who hasn't played football
in four years that's to me and I'm not
saying I like that Mike it's messed up
but that's the reality to the situation
and you and I both know coaches who are
very conservative in nature anyways so
that will be the last hurdle can a coach
or an organization get over that part of
it it does seem like we've gotten over
the hardest part of it too we're
accepting Colin Kaepernick in his fight
and the NFL is entrenched in that and
it's a two-way street Colin Kaepernick
is gonna have to get over his inherent
miss out at this point after three years
of being ignored I think if he would get
a phone call now not did that look if he
had gotten a phone call last week in the
aftermath of Joe la cartes call him that
someone should sign him now and this was
all still very fresh and evolving in raw
I think it would've been a lot more
skeptical than he would be if a phone
call would come today after we saw this
statement from Roger Goodell after we
saw the events of the past few days I
think he would be less skeptical the
question is will that skepticism wane in
time and will a team say hey look the
first step is to invite this guy to come
in and
show us what he's got come in and we'll
work you out we'll take a look at what
you have after three years of not
playing and you make an honest
conclusion as to whether or not he
should be part of the team the danger is
the risk is the problem is if you flirt
with him right you're going to invite a
PR backlash from a certain precise your
fan base you have to be big enough to
say I don't care and also if you bring
him in for a workout and then you don't
sign him then maybe you get a backlash
from the others who are saying you
should sign this guy he should have a
job why didn't you sign him why'd you
just bring him in for a workout this is
baloney this is bogus so you could end
up alienating both ends of the spectrum
here those who are saying no no no to
Colin Kaepernick and those who are
saying why in the hell isn't he in the
NFL you can anger both of them based on
how you handle it but at some point I
feel like the right thing to do is going
to supersede this obsession over making
everyone happy I think what about what
is development say what about Mike - and
you know because you bring up real
points they're great yeah and I'm just
gonna add to it like look what if he
Colin Kaepernick gets signed by a team
and then gets cut at the end of
pre-season I think that could be stuck
could scare teams - right where they're
just go up man you know what if it
doesn't work out the way we thought it
was gonna work out and he's just not as
sharp and it's physically good and
gifted as we thought he was once was you
know that could scare teams off of that
conversation - not wanted to deal with
the backlash if you legitimately didn't
earn a spot on the team but here's my
point here's my point we need to quit
obsessing over people being upset with
decisions that are made with an eye
toward doing the right thing and we just
need to start doing the right thing wait
we're paralyzed by the fear that this
segment of the population is going to be
upset or that segments gonna be upset
just do the right thing do the right
thing for your football team do the
right thing generally do the right thing
for this moment and don't worry about
the consequences
I it's that simple and and I've been
guided by that over the course of the
last two weeks I don't care who gets
upset with me I'm gonna say what I
believe I'm gonna say what I think is
the right thing and I'm gonna try to
pull others along with me or drag them
as the case may be but some of these
teams one of these
hopefully somebody a coach a GM and
owner or some combination of the three
will realize look we could use a better
backup quarterback we could potentially
groom him into a guy who could start for
us depending upon what a given team's
situation is let's forget about that
fringe that's gonna be upset when we
bring him in or the people who are gonna
be upset if we have to cut him or not
give him a job offer when he comes in
for a workout let's just do the right
thing by our team by Colin Kaepernick
and by the the reality of this moment
and understand this is the way football
teams operate all the time guys get cut
guys come in for workouts and they don't
get signed let's not be paralyzed by
fear of what if we don't do this or what
if we do that and I hope someone will
rise above that Chris and do the right
thing no I mean I hear you but I'm just
I'm gonna sit here and again like Colin
Kaepernick got screwed over as bad as
anybody in the history of the NFL we got
screwed over and he is hitting the cause
and the fight in which he is fighting
for is real it's just I we supportive
all the way the reality is from all
those things you just said and we have
quarterbacks coming in the NFL every
year right now and he hasn't played in
three years and I don't know a
quarterback that I can remember and I'm
pretty big into football that had taken
three years off of football and then
come back and had success that to me is
going to be the biggest hurdle at this
point and I don't know if any team would
want to trust that or deal with that I
mean we're not bring him in and see what
he's got no that's my point and see what
he's got and screw anyone who has a
problem with bringing him in to see what
he's got and screw anyone who's got a
problem if you decide not to sign him if
you decide to cut him let's not worry
about public reaction to doing the right
thing let's just do the right thing and
surely one of these owners has enough
money in the bank and has enough as you
would say self confidence in himself or
herself to be the one to say I don't
care if you don't like that we're
bringing him in I don't care if you
don't like that we decided as a football
matter that he's not good enough at this
point we wanted to give him an
opportunity we gave him an opportunity
and you know who knows what happens with
that opportunity who knows if he gets
signed or he doesn't get signed but none
of this goes anywhere until somebody has
the guts to stand up and say I'm gonna
do what's right and damn the
consequences I I get it
I just know as I say I mean you're right
I mean it and it certainly has a chance
to actually be good for business in
certain cities for business okay Chris
none of that crap matters
it doesn't matter shouldn't care about
it they might miss one point Chris no
they should care about in four years
that's what they care about nobody's
bringing a bit I understand it's the
most important point and that's why they
will not be free man yes there's there's
thirty other guys who have played
football the last few years so they're
ready right now why do they fear that
I'm just telling me he's rich you okay
he didn't show it is that much ready at
the last workout I'm just saying that's
where we go that wasn't a rep that was a
that was a dog-and-pony show that got
thrust together and then at the last
minute bring him in for a real workout
see what he has and make your decision
accordingly and don't make your
decisions based upon social media
reaction or what agreement that's like
you and I are gonna say what we're gonna
say is do the right thing you're doing
the right thing bring him in and give
him the fair consideration that he has
not gotten and the fact that he's been
out of football for three years isn't
his fault Chris it's not his fault if
anything that the scale should be tilted
toward giving him the benefit of the
doubt because of the fact that if he's
rusty if he doesn't look good anymore if
he doesn't if he doesn't have the same
zip that he had if he doesn't pick
things up as quickly it's because he
hasn't been in the league because you
kept him out of the league NFL so I
think that should be part of the
consideration - I'm just saying forget
the noise forget the criticism forget
whether or not you're going to lose a
certain percentage of your season
ticket-holders they'll come back the
question is out of 32 NFL franchises who
is gonna do the right thing from a
football standpoint in the first
question you have to ask yourself it's
an honest question do we potentially
need an upgrade
at number two on our depth chart do we
need a potential upgrade are we happy
with who we have could we do better and
they're always thinking that with every
player on the roster Chris can we do
better
can't we do better can we do better it
is a very impersonal exercise they will
throw you overboard in a second if they
think they can find somebody better they
need to have that that candid
conversation internally can we do better
are we willing to explore this from a
football standpoint and ignore the noise
that that's my point they just need to
ignore the noise I'm with you there are
a hundred percent I'm not trying to
fight that aspect of it all I'm just
bringing in the football reality of it
and that's all you know you've been
around these coaches and GM's and all
those things and that's all I'm trying
to say I'm just trying to hit logic when
the football standpoint I'm with you I
want him to be signed
I want people you know I want a team to
fight back against these haters of the
world that would be mad enough and go
you know hey the hell with universe time
that means he's best for our team and
this makes sense for us because that's
the right reason to do it
I'm just saying again as you heard me I
mean it's been three years and that's
not always a hot commodity as far as
playing backup quarterback in football
when you haven't played in three years I
agree with you and the one thing that I
keep coming back to you say I know these
coaches and GM's right I know how
they've been the question is in this
moment at this time are they going to be
different than they right in are they
gonna think of things in a different way
and are they not going to worry about
this that or the other thing and just
focus on doing what's right and doing
what's potentially very right for their
football team by bringing in somebody
who may be better than who currently is
in that number two or even number one
position on the depth chart
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports